il est le premier président américain en
exercice à fouler le sol de la corée du
nord un moment que donald trump a vite
qualifié d'historique
c'est un honneur d'être avec vous et
votre demande de franchir cette ligne
l'était aussi
j'étais fier de la franchir je pensais
que vous alliez peut-être le faire je
n'étais pas sûre mais j'étais prêt à le
faire les deux dirigeants se sont
rencontrés dans la zone démilitarisée
pour parler de dénucléarisation et de
paix après un tweet de donald trump et
pourtant kim jong-un a multiplié les
provocations depuis l'échec du sommet de
hanoi
en février il n'espérait pas un tel
cadeau diplomatique offert sans aucune
contrepartie j'ai été surpris de voir
que vous vouliez me rencontrer et puis
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait une
proposition officielle pour la réunion
d'aujourd'hui
cette rencontre est elle un véritable
pas vers la paix ou un coup de
communication c'est d'abord et avant
tout autre indication pour kim jeewon
d'un point de vue stratégique le
dictateur n'a encore rien gagné plus que
le président aime écrire au final est-ce
qu'on est plus proche aujourd'hui juin
2019 qu'on ne l'était en juin 2018
à la veille du premier semestre homme
qui aime pour ce qu'il a dit
nucléarisation concrètement poser la
question c'est y répondre
au mois de septembre un espoir de paix a
été annoncé par les dirigeants des deux
corées ya eu une annonce à ce moment à
l'autre de dénucléarisation de
rapprochement c'était la fin et c'était
vraiment satisfait parce que pour les
marqueront la réunification est un sujet
critique c'est un sujet de dollars c'est
un sujet qui met de l'avant plan depuis
toujours l'administration trempe espère
une reprise des négociations dans les
prochaines semaines entre deux pays qui
se menacé d'anéantissement
il y à peine un an et demi ici à sync
ryan radio canada montréal